lo que nos preocupa o me preocupa cuando
veo los datos es que la penalidad por
ser mujer si se quiere esa pérdida de
ingreso en relación a los hombres que
ocurren en todos los niveles de la vida
económica canadiense y quebequense en
particular es más pronunciada es decir
en la brecha se acentúa en los
inmigrantes en la provincia de québec e
incluso entre latinoamericanos entonces
de alguna manera el impacto que se vive
todavía más profundamente en esta
población precisa mujeres de origen
latinoamericano que recién en la
provincia de québec triple triple triple
penalidad ahora de vuelta como explicar
eso tal vez las hipótesis que
señalábamos antes puedan tener algo que
ver es decir mujeres que en vez de
quedarse en el hogar como tal vez otras
culturas sin generalizar pero que
podrían decir bueno yo me quedo con los
niños o en una en un rol más tradicional
mientras que el hombre sale a trabajar
las mujeres latinoamericanas tal vez por
una experiencia vivida en sus países de
origen porque en américa latina' las
mujeres están
insertas el mercado laboral de modo
general llegan aquí y también en vez de
esperar el momento ideal o la condición
necesaria para encontrar el vuelo en el
buen salario ingresan al mercado de
empleo
con salarios inferiores también tiene
que ver con sectores de empleo porque
muchas de las mujeres latinoamericanas
entra en un sector de empleo que tiene
que ver con mantenimiento y limpieza por
ejemplo que ya de por sí es un sector
generalmente mal mal remunerado también
ahí hay hay una cuestión de género
porque son empleos
que se orienta más a las mujeres
entonces a mujeres en tanto encuentran
ese nicho
laboral y bueno eso crea pero bueno es
una problemática que va a haber que
investigar porque las mujeres
latinoamericanas sufren más esta
penalidad que las mujeres de otras
culturas u otros orígenes